the promise that lessons will be learned
means nothing to parents like these Mia
Harwood was stillborn in Telford three
days after a damning report blamed the
trust there for more than 200 deaths
there'd been an obsession with avoiding
Caesarean sections with a first child
you don't know any different so you
think oh if they're telling me this is
safe then
carry on but every day I was asking if a
C-section was safer they just kept
saying we'll carry on with the induction
and see what happens Mia's heart stopped
while labor was being induced
had Midwife come up to me and ask what
was going to happen I said well you know
she's gone for a post-mortem and then
we'll get some answers and she said
sometimes they don't find anything and
sometimes it's just you
to have your daughter die and then a day
later someone essentially blame you that
was just the worst thing you can say to
anyone
the trust says no individual should ever
be left feeling that they're to blame
but as scandals emerge across the
country there are similar themes parents
not being listened to understaffing and
in some cases an ideology that favors
natural birth Sky News has obtained this
an NHS guide from 2010 to reduce
C-section rates among the benefits it
lists a sense of Pride and financial
savings the Department of Health and
Social care says it doesn't represent
current government policy but three
trusts who helped write it were East
Kent Shrewsbury and Telford and
Nottingham
love hearts for Harriet it was in
Nottingham that lottie's older sister
Harriet was stillborn midwives offered
us aromatherapy when we had an obstetric
emergency they should have called the
Obstetricians to come and do an
emergency Caesarean section
the Nottingham trust says it's truly
sorry Harriet's death is one of more
than 700 cases being investigated there
there are so many different levels of
failures at the minute within the system
I feel like the complete culture needs
to change they fear the consequences if
it doesn't
there will be other parents like us they
just don't know who they are yet
it is the starkist of warnings from a
family who always have one child missing
Becky Johnson Sky News